am Dienstag findet im Beisein von
Bundespräsident Alexander van der Bellen
und Verteidigungsministerin kaaudia tan
die traditionelle weihnachtsfeer der
Garde in der Marie theresienkaserne
statt Verteidigungsministerin Claudia
Tanner bedankt sich für die erbrachten
Leistungen der Soldatinnen und Soldaten
der Garde Danke zu sagen Ihnen den
Soldatinnen und Soldaten die Sowi das
würde gehabt angesprochen hat leuchtende
Sterne sind leuchtende Sterne sind für
das österreichische Bundesheer weil sie
die Visitenkarte sind im Innland und im
Ausland Bundespräsident Alexander vanon
der Bellen würdigt die Leistungen der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten der Garde die
das ganze Jahr über die repräsentativen
Aufgaben bei Staatsbesuchen wahrnehmen
mit den ehrenkompagnien der Garde Musik
den
treppenspaliieren bler
streicherem mit all diesen Dingen bilden
sie für diesed en Anlässe einen
würdevollen Rahmen der nicht nur von mir
und nicht nur von meinen
Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeitern in der
Hofburg sondern speziell auch von den
internationalen Gästen gewürdigt und
wertschätzend wahrgenommen wird sondern
auch von den beistiners sozusagen die
zufällig oder nicht weil sie davon
wussten am inneren Burghof
vorbeikommen und dort gefallen haben
gefallen finden an der Zeremonie von
Herzen alles Gute und vielen
[Musik]
Dank